all should be you know i mean i don't i
don't think i don't think the only
reason he's saying this is because a
couple days ago he doesn't know this but
i found out he signed up for a new site
called club 17.
what's that
it's probably a porn site
esther you don't sign up for a porn site
no he does he gets a pass where he pays
for it and he's hd
yeah because he needs hd only
what is club 17 well the first one was
alders for youngers and then now the new
one is club 17.
and he doesn't know i know but
oh it's another reveal just now yeah
i belong to different porn sites you do
what is your number what's your budget
i spend like i don't know one of them is
like
100 a year or whatever
they're like a hundred dollars a year
yeah you do the year package
um i don't like um grainy porn
like pornhub is like yeah grainy grainy
you know i mean
like i needed to be clearer
i like newer you know i mean just newer
girls you know and um
yeah i mean i watch pornography and um
i i have certain fetishes
you know i was into a couple of months
ago the the one the old man men and the
little girls not the little girl the
boulders for youngers
that's what the site is like
eight-year-old men and eighteen or girls
is that kiley you can confirm that's
what that is i found out and i had to
confront him on this podcast
and it could be wrong
and uh you know what i stopped watching
that
because he's on club 17 now no no it's
club don't just say something about club
17 okay
he's plugged for that right shut the
[ __ ] up are we allowed to talk about
what what your brother has forced you to
do
no uh yeah
yeah well i don't know yeah that's uh
yeah yeah yeah oh
you're worried about that me yeah i'm
not worried about it well i uh
well i hadn't i had laven i had layman
can you
okay can you reveal that then okay well
because label it's already going to be
out there because it's already going to
go out yeah well we didn't specify but
so when's the last time you spoke to
laban ten years who is labeled
explaining
fighters let me do it he's a pro skater
he's a pro skater he's skated for dog
town
and laban was the first guy to when i
when i was using drugs to give me an
intervention he's a really good dude
yeah i love that guy
yeah he's a great guy he's right yeah i
hadn't seen him in like laban has a
photograph
wait hold up are you going right there
the first guy he picked me up from the
airport
nobody came down there when i first came
to l.a he was there during the dumpster
days no but don't
remember the first time you visited me
and i didn't pick you up nobody picked
you up oh can we talk about that but
nothing happened he left you stranded at
the airport i was stranded at the
airport where was i
i don't know i was in vegas that's when
you live with shama yeah and he had like
[ __ ] 10 cat i got i dude i almost
died like my immune system yeah yeah
yeah oh cause you were allergic yeah but
shayman had a bunch of cats i hated them
so anyway
back to the photo
yeah so anyway
yeah laban was there when i first moved
to la when we lived on uh you know in
silver lake echo park yeah area and uh
yeah man he was your best friend yeah i
love him
but uh he did something what do you do
get to the point what do what you and i
do
i don't know i think one
one night i stuck a uh
it had to do with your butt hole in his
snickers bar
okay
just get directly into it
and you stuck it in my [ __ ] well you
willingly because you wanted him to i
don't know we did yeah wow guys but the
thing is i didn't know i didn't know
what would that you know was there and
um
when he took the picture my face was so
you were inserting it like by the bubble
yeah and laban took a picture of it yeah
so i'm like this like this
and he uh bob had a big birthday party
at the spaghetti factory i used to have
okay so mine was that there used to be a
smell yeah there is a spaghetti factory
on sunset boulevard and i used to do my
birthday parties there and they used to
be the best i'm not kidding you
i mean you know mencia paulie shore
you know my tv people and then all the
comics and skaters and it was a dinner
and and so my brother and i sitting
there at this point where there's 60 70
people there and
dude your manager management was there
yeah abby was there yeah abby was
blaming everyone everywhere yeah my
agent everything and so what laban did
he made multiple copies xerox copies of
my face
of my face
with the snickers bar in his butthole
and then you can see bob's nut sack and
i was like this he's sticking it in his
butt and uh
he passed it around um no it's not it
was basically what everyone that came to
the party
oh
welcome to the welcome to the party yeah
right which i didn't it's like a grab
bag yeah but bobby lee and then what
well it ruined i don't know if remember
i was close to dating someone named rose
yeah and then yeah and she afterwards
she she came up to me and what'd you say
why did you do it
why did you do it steve why and then she
was like shaking oh my god so laban
[ __ ] yeah well he oh this
you know what with him he's a sick
[ __ ] he
he gets off more on the men than the
women
whoa whoa whoa what do you mean no no no
not that you're attracted to the men no
i'm not attracted to the men but i look
it's an awesome here's what it hears
you're like damn this old [ __ ]
[ __ ] this little girl i know but
here's what it is
you know how you can when you see a porn
you can click on like you can see more
videos of sabrina right a girl right and
then you press it and there's like 20
all her photos
all over like work
i don't do that when the i do walter
oh oh you click the guy i picked the guy
who he's worked with yeah who he's
worked with because walter is killing
the game yeah who's walter whatever the
old man's name is yeah yeah how do you
like that so that's where it's gone well
he used to because he used to watch it
for youngers was the other website he'd
like teens for cash into teen stuff for
sure shout out to teas for cash
with all steve what else did i like god
there was although you had like a whole
series i know you're banging you like
like jake steed stuff are you back in
the day yeah i like steve a lot back in
there me too i love jake steve yeah and
uh i i love dude your collection is fast
he still has it oh ed powers ed powers
was he was my man he was my main man
because it was yeah
steve are you sure you're not attracted
to yeah no i like ed powers though yeah
yeah because why do you like power
because it's like he films in his like
these like little
shady little like apartment
you know like in his house yeah his
house yeah yeah and he's
and he's like an old dude so that's i
think that's where my fascination
started because from ed powers here's
what it is and this is what it is and i
don't want anyone to think that i had
this weird fetish what it is is that
these are the closest looking guys to
what i am no they're not yeah i'll tell
you why because ed powers right now i
know but let me just say this though
it's like
what i don't like seeing
buff good looking dudes
have sex with hot chicks you want to see
the i want to see
fat ugly dudes that look like that's
more my category when i first started
dating him his fa we watched his
favorite porn together and it's a gang
bang with like six dudes and one asian
guy and the one asian guy gets like the
last like he gets like the sloppy sixths
but he's just waiting there patiently
yeah but when the guy finally gets it he
nuts
yeah he gets my favorite one because
empowerment it's five white dudes and an
asian guy with one girl right yeah and
she's blowing all these guys and the
asian guy just and then one of his
buddies
what about him
he had to help him and she goes she does
this phase
oh oh smirk scott
yeah and she starts doing him and she he
just nuts right away yeah and he goes
home and goes
he studies for his htt's or something
whatever
so he has a lsat
so he's still he's still masturbates
yeah
it's been day three advent oh my god
day three have you caught him in the
actual ways yeah in the bathtub he
always has to look on him
in the water in the water yeah all you
can hear in the water
little water why do you like the water i
feel like that makes it chafe but every
time i come in he's always like
and he's holding his dick like oh my god
we're [ __ ] up man i know there's
nothing wrong with masturbation
i saw anoko at atlanta i've told this
story before uh mm-hmm
tell it again please i was in a hotel
and anoko what is it
whatever
um he goes what's up to me
and i saw i knew i vaguely knew who he
was
he picked me up like i was a little baby
and he's a skinny
is he japanese yeah yeah he's japanese
he's half though right yes yeah there's
some white in there too yeah yeah and he
picked me up like a little baby and then
you know we took a photo and stuff but
it was very nice but i don't know
anything about it no that's not the
story
the story was you were so
kind of happy you were star struck a
little bit because you pretend you don't
know his name but you know exactly who
steve
and so you saw him at the airport
[Laughter]
i didn't see him at the airport i saw
him at the hotel or that the picture was
at the hotel yes that's the part of the
story okay listen let's talk about that
that's that's the part i lie a lot
correct yeah
i lie a lot i make up things all right
so let's let's go back let's go let's
get to the truth of the story the truth
of the story is this he then took the
photograph and wanted to brag to me
about meeting stephen stop stop that's
where that's where it is that's what it
is
number one i i've i was right i vaguely
knew who he was but i knew who he was
okay
i saw him at the thing i did at first it
wasn't like oh there's steve ayoko all
right so then
when he goes it's steve aoki and i and i
go that i knew that she
in her vegas days would go and see her
shows yeah and like
[ __ ] rubber [ __ ] little [ __ ]
[ __ ] while watching his shows because
she had a little crush crush right but
did you meet him in an airport or a
hotel
that's the main [ __ ] hotel
james i haven't heard a word you said
since then
it's just been bugging
yeah it was
in a hotel you guys then exchange
numbers we do exchange numbers yeah and
then what happened i don't remember what
was it what happened was you were trying
to brag to me that you had just met
steve aoki
and then you instead of sending me the
text oh that's the taunting text you
sent it to me
yes
and then you had to apologize and say oh
my god i was bragging
i was bragging to my girlfriend that i
met steve okay this year and all that
stuff but i sent it to him that's
[ __ ] right and then i had to go um
i'm so sorry it was for my girlfriend i
remember that
that was so embarrassing i blocked it
out babe ryder cause saturday i did a
casino in um sacramento
and as soon as i show up people just
start sucking my dick
not literally but like can we get you
something what do you need are you okay
and i don't need that but papa loves it
and then i can play like
do weird [ __ ]
like i like it when like before the show
people come up to me and they go can i
get a photo i go afterwards you know if
i have time
like i like acting like i'm [ __ ]
special yeah which i'm not
in my i i know i'm a piece of [ __ ]
but there were like moments where like
hey can you just leave the room a little
quiet to be my you know like just i pull
like little power moves dim the lights
please yeah yeah i love doing that [ __ ]
you know yuck
you don't like that and then there was a
restaurant only a restaurant in town
they were closed and i go can you make a
call see they'll keep open for us
damn and they go we'll see they called
me kept open and we were there like
hours late yuck and they this at the
whole shut the [ __ ] up the whole staff
stay and i and i purposely ate as long
as i could and this is a i have a
problem
have you ever oh gosh this is what i
have a problem with because
that was a special day for them wasn't
it
[ __ ] you
superior
if we go to a restaurant and the line is
extremely long and they don't make
special concessions for him they don't
make you know they don't make um
okay you're gonna make me angry because
that you're absolutely wrong what you're
saying right now if no one recognizes
you at a restaurant and they treat you
like everybody else you always say we
gotta go let's leave
you're gonna be upset no i don't yes you
absolutely true or false
i i always stay sweetie we always have
this two hour oh dim young what are the
what's that plays din tai fung ding tai
phong yeah but that's because
that's because people around there were
like taking pictures and they recognized
you that made you happy no but that one
time with my brother we stood we stood
there for two hours and we waited
that's my point my point is a year ago
we did that my point is i will wait
you know and you're wrong what you're
saying
i'm definitely not wrong yeah yeah i've
i've lived with you long enough to know
you yeah you know what you do when
people recognize you you put your hoodie
up and you try to do i don't do that i
have never done that try to hide and
then when they come and you act like
like you have no idea what they're
talking about
do you do the paparazzi
i just lied right just to make you feel
like what i was feeling but i'm not i am
not lying either i'm not lying either
like when fans come up you like you put
your hoodie down and you act indifferent
does that sound like me probably
gilbert does it sound like her though
maybe yeah
maybe that's my point is that when you
lie i lie
and if you're truthful lady i'm truthful
no because this is what you said to me
on um on the way to my sister's birthday
it was you me and my friend shane dee in
the car yeah and you guys got into a
very heated discussion about
being treated um differently by
restaurant owners and you specifically
said that they should be happy that i'm
there for the sake of their business i
never said that
and then she was like no they shouldn't
yeah you're just like every other patron
and you attacked her like you guys were
that one time you got pulled over by the
cop and you cried you go i mean i'm on a
podcast like you shouldn't be giving me
a poc
i'm just saying
that sounds definitely like
i was like
when you lie i lie
i fight lie with lie my friend
and don't [ __ ] around all right yeah
none of that's true and whatever i'm
saying is not true but if you keep
flying i'm going to lie we did have a
meeting at a coffee place there were no
seats and claudia yelled i'm on [ __ ]
tiger belly there we go and you know
what
that's exactly what kalila does that's
what teletech does that's what it does
yeah imagine if i was that way you are
that way what do you mean imagine
just record yourself [ __ ]
you [ __ ] skanky line [ __ ] i hate
people oh god god i would never act like
that yeah you do but anyway let's move
on and i know that
i have never also been pulled over in my
life yeah you have let's move on
but see what i mean
bobby what why
we're going to roll back to a few
episodes ago where he admits to being a
pathological liar that's fine you don't
have to roll back people could just
listen to it
but also everyone listening right now
knows that they slap king right i live
in a deceptive smog
or cloud that's new right and you don't
know what's in it
and that's what people love the mystery
of it i could be lying not lying yeah i
mean left right hook yeah i'm not there
i'm there right now just what i'm saying
right i'm relevant not relevant i mean
all kinds of things are happening right
and that's what the [ __ ] fa and you
kids listening know you know so whatever
this lady is saying kalila is a lie and
i'm the truth listen listen listen guys
i'm a good guy
okay says the guy say again and let me i
wait i wait at restaurants i way to
restaurants yeah like normal guy i don't
complain
can i tell you this one story in
sacramento we went to the sushi spot
and then after this live story i have a
story too okay you go okay go ahead this
is why i want to hear these stories yeah
yeah yeah so we were at sacramento yeah
and our our server wasn't particularly
she was very just neutral she wasn't
very nice she wasn't very
um
mean either she was just very neutral
and he didn't like that
and so
he because he wasn't getting what he
wanted he was scoping around looking at
the restaurant hoping that someone would
recognize him yeah so he was making
himself very visible in the restaurant
hoping that someone would ask for a
picture
and that the woman would then treat him
better
yeah the server would then treat him
better
and so
it worked lies somebody came up and
they're like oh bobby can we take a
picture and then he waited he waited
about 10 seconds to take the before so
the woman would come around the server
would come around and v and see
and visualize the fact that he was
getting asked to take a picture
uh-huh and that's who who is who the
captain is that's okay it's a word
it worked well listen to this queen
this kid is cool oh this is going to be
a good one
i can feel it
because another thing too is like you oh
you're always sour at me man never dog
no i i have like jason tebow go oh yeah
he's really mad you don't even talk
don't say hi to him for a couple of
a couple weeks ago about how you ghosted
yeah yeah you just go there so what
happened
i'm not an assistant i'm old i don't
know street slang yeah all right so
let's
wait wait
for a guy
a guy looks like an emoji you should
know his [ __ ] street
all right so let me say this all right
what does ghost mean that means were you
just like oh yeah i'm gonna do this all
let's hang out and then you just never
reply you never show up you know why why
oh because it's gonna be good this is
gonna be great i can't wait it's already
good i have a feeling you're gonna drop
some like credits on me i go to you
right you deceive me oh
right i i only ghost when people deceive
all right when i see deception or shadow
play going on right i don't play you
armenian folk i love you yeah okay but
let me just say something right now yeah
there's shy shady ones like yourself
yeah yeah and you do shadow play yeah
and it's like you you you lie with them
there's no armies in the shadow plane
that sounds like dungeons and dragons
[ __ ] and we never do that you use verbal
black magic no
right and yeah
see through it okay that's why i don't
show up to your function that's not what
happened what's the story what's the
story this is what i hear
first of all i did his podcast i did
your guys podcast right you you no you
never did it no
no i'm gonna though yeah
and that's you know what it's the
intention that there it is there it is
it's the intention that oh actually it's
showing up
but i did another one what was the other
one i did punch drug love yeah punch
truck right who with me and jcu the
other one the lady that links
oh yeah oh yeah
the fight nanny what's her name candace
candice yeah yes so i did that yes so i
thought i already did it and then you
were like just no no no no dude this was
me you ghost me before that no just
let's go let's go to the the latest
ghost okay the latest
we're gonna go through the history of
the government are we talking ghosting
number three
or number two
because there's number one i'm gonna
tell you but we're talking numbers
you're ghosting yeah i don't think we're
going to do you want to do coaster
i love ghost stories
this is ghost time i have to do ghosting
stories ghost time a tiger
if you want a war let's have a war
okay
see this is what i'm going to say to you
okay then you say to go to do do the
other podcast right
and and i go
and it's i i wake up and it's i thought
i was going to be at the comedy or
somewhere it's in burbank
you don't deceive me that way so you
half show up you went to the wrong place
he didn't even go to the wrong place
i didn't leave the house okay i didn't
leave the house i would have skyped you
in if i knew you had all this we could
skype in yeah but let me just say this
okay
that's my bad
okay
so that's my back
no what what what smells on me
well foot his face oh his [ __ ]
feelings oh my god oh my god the swamp
has you got swamp feet dude i've
actually noticed
they are horrible
like a dead animal is rotting underneath
there uh-huh because we're playing dude
i offered to put powder and just
put baby powder no gold bombs whatever
whatever they got and he goes no dude no
don't touch him
cause i like i'm like what's that smell
we're playing a battlefront we're having
a good time and i go
what's that peculiar smell
in your mind is that peculiar
oh it smells like something yeah and i
go let me smell your your his like
little slippers yeah and i went like
this
oh my god
so you know i i make him watch his feet
before he comes into bed there's fungus
and it still smells awful yeah there's a
fungal infection or something
deep one deep like it's in his blood
so how does it reach to that point of
smelling that bad ask him
he has a regimen
well excuse me what's the ask him to
grow a proper foot fungus
why don't you wear socks
the itch
the socks it started with socks
my my
problem started with the sock
yeah i wear the sock over a shoe and my
feet get really hot
right
and then i don't know why but i
developed a different theory i think
it's from the spa it's not
oh because athletes are dirty yeah
because when i was a swimmer i would get
all sorts of weird [ __ ] on my feet like
i would get one of those like those
warts that go really really deep inside
i would get athlete's foot because that
that moist environment and i'm not
wearing slippers because i'm a [ __ ] i
was a dirty kid he's not he doesn't wear
slippers exactly but
how why then what how do you explain my
right foot in perfect condition i don't
know maybe it smells
they both smell no i do every time let
me spill it right now no let me just say
this okay when i gave you the slippers i
made sure
that you smelled the left one
both of them i smell both yeah but one
of them wasn't as bad
be honest
they're both pretty bad okay they're
both they smell the same
dude it's the same smell it was the same
smell on both right remember i took my
shoe off in the airplane he what do you
mean one time that's like every time
you're in there
from a different she could be like three
seats over yeah three rows in back of me
and she'll go
i i'll literally text them like you need
to put your [ __ ] start with the but
also i will say that i sided with you
steve and i understood your pain at the
moment yeah because i do live with your
brother and i know that he he likes to
push i'm a bad person no you're not a
bad person
you're great you just have a big ass
mouth he's the kylo ren yeah
you don't know where you if you're good
or evil doesn't know so since we're on
this topic yeah how do you personally
because you guys lived together yeah i
we were together for three or four days
and we were kind of butting heads
towards remember kind of yeah i was
getting on your nerves
how do you how do you deal with it
i wanna
there is something that people have to
know about me i am quite possibly the
most patient person that i know how do
you do it with this guy i have the
patience of a [ __ ]
you know my threshold for [ __ ] is so
high
that most things don't get to me you you
deserve a like a oh a [ __ ] message i
know or something i do you do hey a big
one
like the one like the [ __ ] wedding
cake yeah yeah yeah it's like the
[ __ ] gold on the top yeah and like
the massive golden globes mix mixed with
the awesome everything you don't think
that you could live with him today dude
we would [ __ ] get into it if we would
oh i mean we're playing battlefront and
we just being in the same space we we're
not we need to be separate we need to
play games
we are video so that's the one thing we
we've always done together we like we
play we love video games but also he's
really neat and tidy
steve is yeah and bobby is a complete
opposite steve likes things where they
are supposed to be
he literally doesn't he'll just throw it
like no just disregard like yeah every
the world is his trash can sometimes i
feel like he'll like do something i have
to clean up right away and then the del
taco thing that i'm like putting in
there you know you're just following
after him yeah you have to pick up after
you literally you literally have to pick
up how amazing what did the house look
when you arrived and walk through these
doors it was very pristine and how does
it look now after 15 minutes of bobby
you don't even know what he did to our
place in gilbert
it was like the trash compactor it was
literally
it was bad i feel like i sometimes give
maids at hotels yeah
like i'll leave them dvd players oh like
good gifts no but because but they
deserve it trust me because i it's like
you know an aerial view of vmware when
we stay in a ho when we stay in a hotel
together the night before i always clean
up because i feel that bad for
housekeeping and i'm still
we're on to something good you know what
he's bad at also he's bad at this
man like his cars over the years
he doesn't give a [ __ ] that thing might
as well just be a [ __ ] dump truck or
something it is because there is one
truck in poway his uh when he was in
between going from la jolla to l.a he
had a white toyota truck
he had starbucks frappuccino bottles
yeah
like just filled to the top guess what
was inside piss yeah that's his thing he
likes that i like it i like my own pee
i like the color
it's warm jenna and i we cleaned out his
car we found their smells a big block of
what looked like it was like a big block
it looked like a truffle yeah like but a
giant truffle because it was like the
mold had probably looked like it was a
dead body it was a dangerous organic
truffle
dead animal or something right yeah
that's all right 2018 guys and darth
vader i believe it and it's like i'm
ashamed i mean but i need to i'm you
know i need to contain it but maybe not
like i'm an adult and i shouldn't be
but also kind of carrying myself in that
way you know but also you need to
respect his
boundaries he doesn't have to do
anything he doesn't want to do i mean
that the thing is acceptance i have to
accept just the way he is
and if that's the way he is then that's
the way he is i can't yeah but yeah but
no i mean come on man
that's the way you i'm just saying
that's the way i am no no don't don't
don't get it i'm not getting offended
but i want you to know i want you to i'm
asking you a question what are you
saying what do you need that's the way i
am well with certain things i'm perfect
okay
like you wouldn't you don't stop stop
everyone no no no no stop everyone be
quiet i'm not going to say nothing but
i'm going to say this okay
i am a [ __ ] fun machine can i just
say no you are i'm a [ __ ] fun there's
no doubt about sometimes a fun machine
when they're built right there's little
kinks and things right am i not correct
there we go back in the [ __ ] 20s when
they made fun machines when people
decided to do those things technology
was different it was different seriously
this is the problem with bobby
after he apologizes i'm so sorry i
messed up yeah two seconds later i'm
perfect
easy yeah i'm like living in like a
[ __ ] time i don't know how you do it
seriously i'm looking at you and how do
people live with jesus
they couldn't they they were like oh my
god this guy's like building too many
[ __ ] furnitures
he's also walking on the [ __ ] water
and stuff
you know what i mean and people were
like jealous and stuff what am i gonna
do
i am sort of a masochist though i do
like a little bit of chaos yeah yeah you
do so i think that i'm an agent of
[ __ ]
chaos i'm an agent of fun will you look
at me right now well you thrive in it
i thrive in it thrive in it that's the
thing he needs that even the messiness
he needs that to do what he does on
stage and yeah to be a comedian and he
that's what he that's and you know what
i thrive in taking care of somebody so
that i thrive in taking care of that
chaos i commend you i commend you i
commit no seriously he i just i just
realized now like how the [ __ ] are you
doing this
i don't know how you're doing then you
have five there's a zoo in here now you
got an animal
what's next like a bird or a parent
so many animals gotta get a parrot and
there's so many animals and dealing with
him dealing with what perfection
[ __ ] you man i'm sorry i love you we
have a question guild we do yeah is this
live no no it's not alive
if this was live
unhelpful advice with bobby kalila and
stevie weeby
this is from brian in los angeles
california as a korean american it has
been difficult for me to understand
where our community stands culturally i
want to have pride in my community but